dude I'm on the thicker side now that's
why the big boy when I see you like I'm
like he looks thin then you get up close
you're like no I'm never like 225 like
my normal walk like right now I'm like
almost 240 so I'm gonna up you haven't
worked out in a while so I probably get
out of like walking away like 2:30 right
but you know yeah just what hates yeah
uh-huh
six you're big in six six six six hey
okay cuz your weight on ya cuz you're
listed six seven seven isn't something
with it was six eight they just never
changed it how about how about he was
better football than yeah I know you
played football that's crazy
what was your receiver imagine guarding
mmm-hmm I saw I saw old pictures you are
the tallest receiver yeah is there its
receivers no there's no six eight
receivers Randy Moss was six a car
Harold Carmichael play for the Eagles
back in the day was like six seven Wow
there's been so many I mean it is it's
very brave a team or any monster six six
I think I think Ramos for take it you
think although Gronk who's a tight end
is he's probably six six right six five
okay but when you're that tall they're
just not usually that the speeds now
yeah and I ran a 439 in high school yeah
yeah is that true yeah and Vegas at the
combine yes Jesus okay six six huh yeah
well that's a Wikipedia thing yeah so
it's not sure yeah you had six for crazy
but what did you get you get recruited
for football yeah but you knew
basketball was the path Oh Papa I think
I could have pray flow I just figured
probably more because it was kind of
unheard that the best ballplayers
weren't really you know now it's like a
new thing where cosplayers never played
football they're jumping too tight in a
plane in the NFL like I really played
football but there just wasn't guys my
size really doing it like tony gonzalez
was kind of a two-sport athlete in
college but there wasn't really bad guys
my size doing it so I stuck with
basketball after my sophomore year I
went out at for spring football with
Coach Toledo out there do really well
when
I can talk to the lab and the ad and
we're gonna change of scholarship and
you're gonna have to move out of the
dorms and you're not gonna be a captain
no I'm like just kind of like all kind
of [__] like just cuz I want to play
football
where today would be completed football
and basking in what sense kind of bored
dogs like you have to like that's why I
played basketball the way I did it was
because I was a football player like I
just love physicality I love being
aggressive I don't mind being hit
I don't mind hitting back you know it
was always my must I was a football
player that [__] around and played for
what especially coming up when you came
up and then be a there's I feel like
there's more dogs back then oh yeah
there is now such an offensive nows game
Scott I think kids are more skilled now
because there's more training at a
younger younger age but I think there's
less of like a basketball IQ because we
used to just play all the time and
wasn't working out you know we'd go
outside and play basketball at any time
there wasn't so much skill training and
fundamental work it was just get your
ass outside and play mm-hmm now it's
just like pay trainers and wait coaches
at nine ten years old which is crazy
guess couples working out now no no I
mean all I do is run bike and then I box
your box hey Matt let me deal with your
jab me in the face yeah the guy who's
just super athlete let's go let's go
spar well I do you ever sparred here I
have a spa I did one light sparring
session maybe three years ago I was only
one it's awkward that was now like even
as good an athlete you are job boxing is
tough yeah I mean hats off to be able to
take a punch and knowing that how much
energy you extend on a missed punch like
it's just a lot of [__] they're calling
shots seeing them mm-hmm yeah do you do
you obviously keep up the NBA now I see
on first Aiken I just did a you're great
on that but you did wake up anyway get
up this morning get up yeah I love get
up man yeah it's good I like greenberg
he's good he's really good there's a lot
to talk about but I'm gonna ask an
ignorant question which you might get
mad at you playing against Kobe what he
played with Kobe what if if you have you
know I'm sure even ask this but I just
love these questions if you had if you
have your all-star team and you have a
choice between Kobe and Michael
would you choose oh that's good call I
thought you're gonna say Kobe and LeBron
oh yeah that what a [__] Kobe I'm to me
Mike's the greatest yeah so I pick Mike
because he was a better teammate er nah
that's not necessarily true they're both
[__] like I know we never knew what
kind of [__] Mike was until we got to
see it on that documentary but Kobe was
the same way Kobe oh gosh you guys try
to I mean certain guys I've heard that
you out try to fight you do [__] to kind
of push your buttons to motivate you or
Michael to say well Sheree
didn't he ever push you well we got in
so you know we almost got in a fight and
that's how I ended up coming to the
Lakers when I faked the ball in his face
how about we're on Akeem knobs on
Orlando okay you know cobras it's a
tough-minded [__] mentally and
physically obviously skilled and gifted
but he always wanted to have that that
that mental you know advantage too so he
would do all kinds of grabbing elbow and
cheap shots kind of within the game
quote-unquote and I just wasn't having
it that day cuz I kept getting call for
the files like we almost fought him and
then he called me and asked me if I want
to come to the team at oh that's a dog
that I need he did that one yeah me and
me and Ron Artest both backed off years
that's not a winner
it's like I'm tardy [__] trying
to beat me up so I saw I talked to one
of his teammates and well maybe I can
say it Carlos Boozer yeah sat next to me
and Carlos told me that Kobe like
decided he called Carlos like three in
the mornings like with hello I was like
I don't want Jeremy Lin on my team like
he was he went but he was he would yell
to Jeremy because and he said I'm not
going on the court with you because
Jeremy was he was a great player yeah I
might be am i speaking out of turn
Carlos you know but but it was just so
obvious that Kobe was just basically
calling us
I don't want him on my team I don't need
to be on the team and Carlos is talking
on like people groups Esav yeah super
obsessive he was a like a beautiful mind
almost how much he obsessed over being
the best he can absolutely be like you
have tons of god-given talent but that
[__] worked he was working out
before the Sun came up in the offseason
every day I used to go
to Orange County and work out with him
sometimes we're up on the track before
the Sun comes up waits for hours we lift
weight so hard the first time I'm like
bruh how the [__] you expect me to shoot
now like my arms are like jello but then
I heard that we're on the court you know
he said he was a he was an animal you
guys did the all the smoke podcast with
him
I mean what before he passed away no we
released it two weeks before he passed
away we shot it and at the end of
December okay but I would see coab every
other weekend because he coached Gigi
and I coached my twins
so all you know they're in the same
circuit she was 13 my kids are 10 where
10 at the time so we're always girls and
boys similar age they're all named Trent
not two boys two boys so we're always at
the same tournament because there's
always a girl side in a boy's side he
would always go out of his way hit me up
like hey if you guys didn't train me let
me know what time you play so I hit him
with our schedule and sometimes it'd be
two hours before we play he would sneak
up and and with his security and check
out my boys team out and go come before
after I would go we've got his games
when we were done so I would see him
pretty much every other week have your
boys inherited a lot of your athletic
gifts they have their needs so much more
skilled than me because like I said I
didn't I didn't work out work out for
basketball until I got to the NBA till I
was 21 like my kids are working out for
basketball I get eight and nine years
old it's my uh they're they're pretty
average sides right now they don't stand
out but the doctor said they're gonna be
at least six four if I'm maxing my
youngest cuz I have my have two
different baby mamas my youngest my ex
both my ex's are basketball players but
the twins mom is like five six but my ex
that I just had their baby with she's
almost five ten and a half so we just
got him tested the other day and the
doctor said at least six six so the
baby's gonna be bigger than everybody
yeah kind of a head start
yeah and he's a lefty yeah so well
what's funny is in a lot of pro athletes
go to my nephew's are both athletes mhm
but they're at their school Campbell
Hall there are a lot of like pro
athletes who have kids there and my
nephew had a party for all the kids at
you know my uncles I mean my
brother-in-law's house and you could
just see who was the child of the
professional athlete I was like who are
the men they're kids they just giant
yeah it is like what
yes different do you are you obviously
keeping up with NBA now they're gonna
they're gonna go back why end of July
and July yeah can be weird don't rights
gonna be yeah it's gonna be you know we
playing without fans is something we
never fathom because there's so much
energy given off from fans you know what
I mean like we do it for our fans so the
first argument well we can never play
with our fans but then basketball got
taken away from us or them you know for
the last three and a half months like
okay well [__] well you know we just
want to get back on the court so I'll be
insured to see what kind of arenas they
playing because if they play a
normal-size arena's a thirty thousand
seat arena like we play and it's gonna
be too hollow but I think if they play
like in practice facilities and smaller
facilities where it's you know more
proportion the Deaf perception is
different
it'll be fine it's gonna be at that
world wide to sports I that's pretty
small yeah I think it's pretty it's not
huge yeah that's good what else is
waiting you tell me how you feel about
this they're gonna be in this playoff
run but they're gonna be quarantined
right so the pleasure me finds FB
quarantine even though Walt Disney
wasn't me open I can stand line so they
can go they can't do that it's gonna be
a quarantine and check this out their
family and friends can't see him for the
entire run
why thought there's getting some weeks I
I thought you got one I wanted to say
you get one person or you got something
maybe if your family does see you they
have to come quarantine first and it has
to be like immediate family like there's
some I don't really know the verbage but
it's gonna be weird i but but also from
a standpoint of it's almost gonna be
like you know back in the au times were
you know the big a you terms for all the
dope players are in one place you know
kind of hanging out like we kind of got
away from that like that back with
basketball was fun i think there's gonna
be some cool stuff that comes out of
that but it's definitely gonna be
awkward
I'm excited least and is it crazy too I
think with the rest and all that I think
the Lakers are that the face well you
know Brahms never had this kind of rest
no not I mean lady yeah you know but
then you say the same thing about Paul
George in Kauai so to me it's the the
it's coming back to LA I just don't know
who I'm gonna bring it but I think by
that like probably like the the
Conference Finals then definitely when
they get into the the championship
series I think they're being back to the
arenas I'd be awesome that's why things
gonna happen they're gonna start there
and then you see with this corona stuff
and my guy we all start limb people
is how are you gonna have them
quarantine but then as the season goes
on the NFL some fans
mmm obese having fans are they both
started states are going yeah are they
yeah like Texas is there's you can go to
movie theater Notre Dame Notre Dame said
we're gonna have fans in there we'll
figure out a way to space it's not
school what happened canceled until til
which I'm will call it second quarter
out until January that just no place no
because the college is like all college
football players are back on campus
mm-hm can you start taking away the
money the funding from the school then
figure out really you can't do this also
they're not dying kids are not affected
by I'm so so we have major gaps in
learning this is not this remote
learnings not working well it's funny
because I asked my ex-wife you know my
kids are transferring to a Heritage
Christian um this year and I'm just like
you know this might be in everyone does
it but this might be a good reason like
now or you know toward the end of the
school year is where you apply
everything you've learned and obviously
we both talked about this offer like the
online schooling our kids received
wasn't the same quality as it was while
they were in schools are they gonna be
ready for that next grade you know my
kids are jumping to junior high you know
a bigger be ready he'll gonna be ready
mentally to uh you know handle what
junior I feel different thing you know
it's scary yeah what back to them be I
thought it was weird to that they did it
oh this is hilarious to me I think it's
the Zion Williams rule Williamson rule
because you know we're gonna allow 22
teams that's oh yeah another one I on in
there the young talent you know that's
what this next generation is you know
these kids are coming into the NBA with
bigger followings than their teams you
know I didn't mean like scion came in
with the bigger following than his team
John Moran came into with a bigger
following than his team so there's you
gotta find ways at the young young and
next generation the next wave in this
playoff format specially cuz it's gonna
be you know a once-in-a-lifetime thing
for the NBA did did you think Zion was
gonna be as good as he is
I did really I mean obviously I waited
because you know I mean he was just he
hasn't even really learned how to play
basketball and when I say that like it
takes you about a good three or four
years maybe five years to get a feeling
for the league and until you really
start that the game slows down and you
understand it he's just been pure
athleticism in raw talent yeah and you
saw how good he was when he came back
you know what I mean and in and it's a
different game you know if this was the
early 2000 or you know the late nineties
were you know power forwards are really
610 250 you know in me like power
forwards now we're stretched power
forwards or like there's 610 like 220
yeah I mean cuz they play outside so
it's not necessarily now it's more so
much more of a skill and finesse game
than it is being a man and being
physically strong so you know he's
physically as gifted as we've ever seen
as far as athleticism some once he
starts to translate and understand the
game more and play with pace and
understand the look tricks to the game
he's gonna be his dominance he wants
he's funny how bodies have changed like
I was watching finally made in America
on ESPN Oh Jay Simpson thing like okay
yeah and and watching OJ's as dominant
as he was if you actually look at him it
was before people were training or
lifting he's thin I mean he's big but
he's thin his legs are fairly thin wiry
strong arms and wire is strong but you
you wouldn't see that necessarily in the
and it's actually nothing running back
no no no but then there's also guys you
know he's a wide receiver but he was
special but then there's also guys like
bo Jackson or Jeff then you look at the
same time Bo Jackson's there they have
Marcus Allen there who's completely
different builds yeah you know what I
mean it's like you it's like yeah but
now it's just these kids are so much the
skill level in all sports I think is has
risen you know due to just the change at
a times and you know the internet and
everything being accessible I mean I
would look at stuff and do stuff and
realizing that you know it and I think
it's unfortunate because I think kids
miss a part of their childhood you know
we used to just play outside until the
lights came on like yeah play tag ride
bikes do whatever it was now you spell
that's I'm saying they make it a job so
early half you know what I mean and I
think that's why some kids get burned
out every parent thinks their kid is the
one that's gonna make it so they like
live vicariously through them and I see
it on my team that I coach you know
sometimes I see some of these kids I
have one kid on my team that's so talent
by the most talented 11 year old I've
ever seen but to me what's the point of
being the most talented 11 year old like
there's no money
yeah like you want a peek and be
mentally and physically ready at 1718
when it's time to make that jump to the
pros or college but you know you got
young kids working out five six days a
week and although it's fun like it's not
kid fun you know that's more here if you
look at the stats like in tennis and
things like that the kids that are
ranked nationally under 12 almost never
go on to be I'm sure what they could be
burnin yeah yeah so someone like Federer
played all the sports as a kid yes it
was always had a ball as here too and
then he didn't take tennis seriously
till he was 15 so what they do now is
they try to now they're realizing that
range for anything right anything is
that great book range about sort of like
you know if you look at the most Nobel
Prize winners in science they are 15 or
20 times more likely to be also
tinkerers in you know other things
poetry music yeah it makes total sense
yeah I mean I played football basketball
baseball track in high school like I
didn't even take a recruiting trip
because I was always in this season what
did you run laundry I run the relay I
run the 400 and the 200 but that was
super super blazing track fast cuz I
never really got the techni I was just
out there because I love to run and it
kept me but I was fast for my size
obviously yeah so I was just always into
something like I said I didn't to hear
like when people here like said that
like I didn't work out for the NBA until
I got to the NBA like that's crazy
nowadays you know I mean that you know
kids are working out at ten years old
sometimes even earlier than that you
know so but to me I was a kid like I've
got in trouble I stole gum from the
liquor store even might have played in
the creeks like I just did a little bit
in Sacramento
okay you know so I just did kids
speaking there yeah we just for the yeah
for the protests in the March yeah so
but up but also I feel like something
you and you didn't come up with him well
you came up with a little bit I guess
what a lot guys got a deal with it now
social media yeah like you got to tell
it I caught the tail end of it yeah
because you know you get done with a
game and then you might get some media
or when you're walking out the arena
fans might shout something but then it's
over really or you know there might be
some local news when I take some heat or
some Tommy show 24 hours now it's like
dudes are getting on they're checking
their Instagram so I got [__] game do
you can't believe you missed that and
they're paying attention to our sorry
banter ants my favorite player by his
hands down to me
have to do in the NBA I love Kevin
Durant when I found out he had burner
accounts I was brokenhearted have you
heard of it uh no no well he had fake
accounts like skip bayless yeah they
take outs and he was chiming back at
kids like kids like you laugh at it he
probably needed a car so it's different
because I don't think people understand
like we all have a level of criticism
but you know he went from being like be
loved by everyone when his mom was the
real MVP and have the emotional speech
where Kevin are Kevin Durant was you
know that like the poster board for the
NBA to the next season or the our season
tour after that like going to the words
in the world hating him you know we
talked about it on the podcast and to me
Kevin yeah I was like you know it's like
you're Kevin Durant who gives a [__]
about these people like cuss him out
from your phone like yeah why'd use a
burner account and he this this and that
and that he's like I'm still gonna use a
burner can you and I like the fact that
because I'm someone that fires back to I
think people think and I'm sure you guys
get it too with the platform we have
people think that they can just say
anything to us yeah we're not human Oh
turn your shoulder be the big man [__]
they're like if you say someone's gonna
annoy me enough or disrespect me enough
I'm gonna say it back to me because I
just wish people live I'll like don't
say nothing you wouldn't say to my face
that's how I which they never would it
should be a principal just don't say
nothing you wouldn't say you're given
these dozens of this wholly yeah where
they you know how how ain't concern how
stupid you have to be to fire something
at Kevin Durant way to go dude I was
telling I'm watching I'm watching the
fights with a bunch of actors a lot of
them pretty famous and stuff and they're
all but we're watching we're watching
Anthony Joshua and Andy Ortiz fight in D
Rouge I'm Andrew any race fight and
we're watching them fight and these guys
went box in their whole life and by the
way Sugar Ray Leonard is there yeah now
shut the [__] up around Sugar Ray watch
good and I got people criticizing the
fighters just why don't they catalyze
fights of the night and to your point
about
like saying something bad about somebody
and we know a comic who got chewed out
by another comic because he went bad on
on her and for me and in that comic goes
hey [__] you gonna say that [__]
to one and said [__] to my face you
remember you told me the story oh yeah
yes yeah but the point is oh yeah
supported I'm not gonna say anything
you're right the comic laughs form and
trash talk somebody unless I'm on a fire
I swear to God
why don't you think it's just tough for
you no because like I said we give
anybody a voice now and you know you
made it to the highest level
professional fighting you made it to the
highest level in your profession like
it's hard to get really hard it's
because it feels easy everybody to do it
everyone would be really the call weighs
hard it's and that's not just we in any
profession when you get to the top it
takes a lot of work dedication sacrifice
everything but then you give people a
chance to just say whatever knowing got
damn well they probably can't even tie
their shoe and you know chew gum at the
same time or hey you know so it's just
like right you know what I love about it
yeah a lot of us Joe want to be Maps you
know chances in their lives so they see
you living with other people right yeah
I I love when you know one thing I love
and I use just pay attention to is when
during NBA games we'll have fans come
out and shoot free throws or make layups
or do some kind of contest during
timeouts make a [__] layup airball
you free throws have to like you're the
same [__] people booing and scream at
us telling us and we suck and you can't
even make a layup you year see what
Deonte while they're did to troll so you
know
heavyweight champ of the world at one
time the this guy kept rolling them kept
drama he's like dude come to my [__]
gym cuz the guy would like he's some
small white dude who think I'll [__] you
up if I ever see you yeah after I was
like come to the gym bright come to
Jimmy dude shows up today he's crazy
though well the dude shows up in Deonte
knocks in the [__] out no way yeah well
damn yeah please he kept falling down
but he's crazy this guy's Charlie his
name is Charlie Zelle and selling off
he's completely what was this research
aliens boxers and he's out of his mind
and tries to finalize look you spend
most of your life sleeping all I hear is
amazing things about helix mattresses
they are not your generic generic
mattress okay they you take a quiz takes
two minutes to complete they match your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you this is custom
sleeping you only spend a third of your
life doing it why wouldn't you if you're
a side sleeper you a hot sleeper you
like a plush or a firm bed with helix
there's no more confusion no more
compromising on an average mattress
you'd have to go there and lie down I
match this helix sleepers even were the
number one best overall mattress 1019
2020 by GQ and Wired magazine all right
if you give me a 10 year warranty I'm a
freak out dude you know how many people
try to sleep at my house cuz off helix
my you sleep on the helix my do I sleep
on Papa sleep hard you know 110 lbs one
to ten yeah an 11-day hey that's from
the hole you ever sleep on a freaking
cloud the Hart helix dot-com stash
spider take their 2 minutes sleep wish
they will match you a customized
mattress ok
that's it then there's a 10-year
warranty so you get to try it for a
hundred nights by the way risky if you
don't like it you don't like it up pick
it up you don't have to worry if you ask
elix is offering up to $200 off all
mattresses orders and free pillows for
you guys helix sleep calm slash fighter
that's helix sleep calm slash fighter
for up to $200 off
you gotta optimize - you got to be a
total human you gotta have high blood
pressure you can't have high blood
pressure you gotta have you gotta have
supplements that you actually believe in
that are safe you don't want to get
stuff you don't know you because you
don't know how supplements are made
you just don't there's no there's not
enough regulation on it what's on it you
know how it's made the owners themselves
take the products all the time I've seen
that with my own eyes I take the
products you got shroom tech support I
mean support if you want can the
president of the fig boy bike club speak
up yes cry before every ride I like to
brew the dark rose and is called the
[__] yeah coffee collection I've gotta
cry fun on it
go ahead brew that and it powers me
through about 25-30 miles
I like that very much you've got your
you've got all kinds of supplements that
optimize your training all realize your
recovery that optimize your sleep that
optimize your memory all kinds of stuff
how about you deep throat a white
warrior bar for the for the face well
that's what I brought when I was hunting
with Joe Rogan and everybody wanted a
piece of that elk warrior we want a
piece of you huh they're so good the elf
parts the elk bars are the best I can
save 10% off everything supplements
nutrition fitness apparel everything
including the [__] yeah coffee or thank
audit dot-com slash fighter 10% off you
welcome how crazy is he's already got a
Samsung flip phone so he's twenty
fourteen and you know he's just talking
smack dominant shows up he actually
doesn't rise to find if he's going to
take his head off
dude he's never boxed he's not a boxer
nobody is though these guys online none
of them but this guy's actually crazy
and he goes and tries to challenge you
every pro boxer including Mayweather's
father and starts swinging really hard
he's gotten beaten up so badly look
a-here may get the hell out the way Oh
get up oh you caught him a negative oh
yeah and people who don't know Deonte
water if you're watching this he's the
nicest coolest guy in the world so think
how bad this guy's been trolling it slot
man people that people understand that
man it's you know I asked Kobe in our
interview I'll just like you know what
are some of the stuff that that stood
out from the media or people that said
nasty things to you that stood out to
you and he paused and looked and he said
all of it like I heard all of it you
know me like that [__] hurts you know
we're human we're ready we just happen
to get paid you know
good amount of money to do something but
we're still human and I think people
lose that you know because we've made it
to the top that okay well they make a
lot of money it doesn't matter yeah
because he's rich it's good it's okay to
do it never what's weird is like with
you or Kobe or Steph Curry and I can go
through a list of guys I don't see it
really affecting them I'm sure some of
you guys see it but then with Kevin
Durant because I love him so I can it
weighs on who like he has the hoody up
and you can tell he's like he's thinking
about them like dude you're the best
mother [__] on the I don't want to do
I don't believe I'm not listening to
good or bad because I think the same the
same critic the same when you get you
know satisfaction from somebody saying
good things mm-hm
be careful because we're all too
sensitive I'm too sensitive the world
owes you much like 80s comics or movies
that would eat the words they're using
is people that lose their mind in a
vacuum Nick Nolte and Eddie Murphy I
forgot what movie I was just watching
another one hours and he was [__] this
[__] I was like oh god about you know
but it was a normal dialectic you know
amongst each other in a movie like now
people to lose their mind you know he's
pretty straight you know to mean so I
think overall you know obviously it's a
sensitive time with race and everything
but I mean I just think overall you know
we're very it's just different now you
know what I mean and every you respect
and love everyone but we're very
sensitive I'm amazed at how in 2020 and
especially at fifty three to see how
sensitive we still are understand where
I was you know watching this [__] oj
thing yesterday I mean but huge part of
the first episode is about police
brutality in I think it was what's in
and in Watson and by the way the police
department the the chief of police was
white and everybody all the other police
were white they had nothing to do with
those communities so they would go in
they'd never been there they would go in
to apprehend the criminal quote-unquote
and take him out so then they'd be a
riot
and they would go in with tanks so you
became an occupying force but there is
no doubt and they had it on film that
there was clearly police brutality over
and over again we're still dealing with
it I do think it's gotten better
you have to say that because otherwise
all the efforts that went into making it
better by a lot of people of color
especially black people would go
unnoticed however I'm just amazed we're
still dealing with it yeah I was trying
explain somebody who you know people say
you haven't say anything about this and
I said I'm gonna shut the [__] up for
about a week this is not my place right
now let me shut the [__] up maybe two
yeah and we talked about this because
this is a catharsis and if you study the
history you see that this is a catharsis
that this this somebody was because if
you hit people with facts and stats it's
not the time it may be that things
policing has gotten more sensitive this
it may be it's become more diverse but
that was the cherry on this on the
[__] ice cream bomb sundae
it feels oh yeah let it is it's it's
just you got to think policing most
people to know policing started as like
slave Wranglers that's how policing
started you know early on so police
started as slave Wranglers and then once
they abolish slavery they do you know
they had the Jim Crow law and you know
we're arresting people pretty much for
anything so to me anything rooted and
founded in hate you know they're they're
still hate now and I think the fact that
you know it hasn't to me it hasn't
changed it hasn't gotten better the only
thing now just being filmed but they're
still able to get away with the
quote-unquote they say one percent of
officers that kill people are charged
and less than one percent of convicted
so it's just a free very hard range you
know what I mean it's hard and I'm
working with lawmakers in Sacramento
they said the two hardest unions to
crash are the police and the teachers
union that's why kids don't know them
then please do what they want because
their unions are so strong you know I
mean so to me I'm not someone that
agrees that we can live without police I
mean I think anyone that thinks that is
crazy because there's real-life crazy
people out here like most of us most of
us are trying to do the right thing
there's really people that are always
going to take advantages of peaceful
protest people always gonna take
advantage of any situation and that has
nothing to do with color that's just
people there's just some bad people but
I do believe it needs to have a major
overhaul to a major reform because you
know that you know the the budget for la
52 percent of the budget la is LAPD 52
percent you know some when people say
the fund is not necessarily abolishing
the police department but it's
using some of that fun you know mayor
Garcetti cut 150 million dollars out of
it off their budget but that's nothing
compared to what they're actually he's
also not a left-wing thing guys it's
very important to realize that both
sides of the aisle secretly agree that
police unions fire and safeties unions
and I'm a supporter of both for sure but
they're very powerful unions and they
get the lion's share you don't get
elected unless you are you're alone with
the yes unless you are a voice so when
they say do you fund the police you have
to understand that that money would go
to it's not gonna be you're not gonna
your neighborhood will be policed it's
gonna go to other programs that could be
very fun boys and girls clubs and things
like that my feeling is that if you if
we if the black community especially and
I can't speak for them but I'm gonna
speak for government mm-hm if the black
community communities of color are
relying on the federal government are
relying on left-wing or right-wing
anybody if they're relying on that you
tell me how that's been going for the
past 50 years right so so my question is
yeah and I think the debates happening
already in the black community what does
the black community do it's like that
famous quote by Malcolm X who said if
somebody throws you in a hole don't
expect the person who threw you into a
hole to pull you out of the hole and I
think that's as relevant as so what is
do so what does the black man I think
unite and have a plan I think to be
honest with you black community are our
biggest you know we're our own nemesis
you know obviously police brutality is a
huge thing but I think the fact that we
don't come United on any fronts and this
is not to speak down but Asian community
they have each other's back the Jewish
community have each other back the
Mexican community have each other back -
that doesn't mean the whole time they're
always agreeing or are loving so to
speak our community our neighbors our
brothers our sisters but would they
understand that you know you sacrifice
this time now that you know you're gonna
have you know you're gonna be well off
later and I think the black community
never really has unity so to me coming
together first and foremost you know to
me that's coming together realizing that
hey we're all in this fight together and
that's blacks first but then everyone
else who wants to follow us I think
that's great as well but then having a
plan understanding voting you know when
we say vote it's not just if everyone
wants to Trump out the white house it's
not about getting trumped by the white
house although I think that's important
but to me it's boating on your local and
state level because that's where all the
bills are created and passed and people
to understand that you know
understanding
you know who your council members are
you know the mayors and how important
district attorneys are you know district
attorneys got their pockets wide open
like you said everyone has a hand to the
police officers there was a situation
where I did a stuff the Stefan Clarke
rally in Sacramento two years ago when
the cops shot him eight times six times
in the back no one was charged but right
before that
Amory Schubert the crooked DEA in
Sacramento was supposed to make a ruling
she got a four hundred thousand dollar
donation from the SAC PD and I'm remiss
cuz I always think of myself as
up-to-date on stuff III have I was
talking to somebody who's involved in
local politics I came here and told you
this I felt like a white belt I didn't
know [__] yeah I there's no take you
years to why that's something I mean I
eventually want to be mayor of my
hometown so I'm doing a lot of stuff in
Sacramento working with you know
bringing businesses there and in working
with the mayor and the police chief to
kind of bridge the gap on certain
projects but you know I just had an
amazing meeting with a guy named Richard
green yesterday and I had probably
bought five or six
you know urban platform you know people
have big platforms in our urban space
and we're trying to teach pot like make
politics fun you know make it under so
people understand how important and it's
not so much about say oh I don't like
politics that's crooked that you know
the Republicans and Democrats are mean
everyone is politics is nasty yeah you
know you can't say Democrats are good
and they'd always do good and or you
know vice versa sort of it's all nasty
in there but be passionate about a cause
like something you're passionate about
like just vote for that you know you
register and vote for that cause you
whatever you feel is near and dear to
your heart whatever touches you because
we can't make everyone want to vote for
the president or want to vote for
certain things but they're I guarantee
if everyone looks into you know the
election in things are up for debate and
think that we have control over the
community you can find a handful of
thing that you're passionate about it
and vote about those things that's
started out right and then still that's
when you start with that then you start
learning more and understanding you know
once you learn politics it's very
interesting and realizing how much power
we do have especially as the black
community and then minorities as a whole
you know if we all came together and
understood how important it is
I love the word marching and rally and I
didn't really like the burning down the
buildings and looting and all that [__]
but to me
we've been peacefully protesting cap
took a knee we've been putting our fists
up peacefully for 400 years and Ness
and nothing happens so the first time
now the world finally hears us you know
so what's so after now that they hear us
what is the next step you do now what's
the plan now we have to happen right you
know what I mean so for the first time
everyone has our attention you see huge
four and five fortune 500 companies
saying stuff donating money and this is
not the first black man that's been
killed this shit's been happening for a
long time before it's finally like the
one like you said that was the cherry on
top like we saw someone be executed in
front of our own eyes you know so far
and even with that being said there's
still people that want to bring up his
past and his upbringing and he was not
for $20 you know not for $20 especially
when you have these these young white
kids that are doing these mass shootings
that are getting taken to Burger King
you know should know we're also like not
that it matters at all but they were
cocaine convictions a lot of times you
get coke on them and stuff scattered
ramela stuff matter what I was telling
people with I mean you can be a vegan
yogi healthiest person world if someone
puts the knee on your neck for nine
minute you're gonna die you [__] how
healthy you are never wrestle with him
haven't graduated grizzly bear use it's
just forgive them give 30 seconds and
tell me we don't talk about how
uncomfortable just to lay on your
stomach period you know the mute on the
road on the ground and you're on family
oh you mean you had I'm saying your
bodies all going through crazy stuff to
you're laying on the ground with you
know maybe you have one guy on you've
been to other guys on you is that so bad
- that to show you do all the smoke
which I think it's fair to say and I go
out I go out internet trolls all the
time with this you guys literally have
the biggest by far basketball show and
you want just talk sports in general
it's up there man I was just talking to
our boy Brian daily about this the other
day man you guys show us so big so big
and your partner on that show Stephen
Josh and Stax he was really close in the
mix yeah people don't realize it yeah
call for the twin this twin yeah a
little side demo I didn't know there
obviously the relationship they had
until it happened in Jack and I've been
speaking for it because two weeks ago
yeah I think he bought him collecting
out clothes and stuff just sends up a
bunch I mean we get so much stuff and
then you know we go through so much
you know I I have people I donate to all
the time so that that was someone that
Jack would just give you know when we
stuff we don't like or doesn't wearing
or something we don't marry into you
know donate to something my first six
foot seven right you know I mean it's
hard to give it away you know so that
was you know come to find out that was
Jack's brother and it was I've just been
so proud of him because you know I've
been in this space that social justice
space speaking up on it for a long time
and it really weighs on you but he
really jumped in the middle of a frying
pan like this is this like he says it's
a revolution you know what I mean and
he's at the forefront of it speaking on
it bringing people together consulting
the family doing everything he
absolutely can with this platform to to
bring attention to this business grab
from each in and it's and it's it's
draining you know I had them the other
day it's just like you know you can't
let this consume you make sure you're
getting rest getting some sleep you know
smoking turning off your electronics and
just taking time for you because this
hurts you know what I mean like I don't
care what color you are like you're
feeling what's going on right now and
I've been on top I get I get for me I
feel like I can't do anybody to do you
know there's not much anybody can do but
just it got to a point where you know I
was on top of it I was posting all the
police brutality stuff and all the
negativity and I yeah yeah it's a like a
lot of people are jumping on it which
it's good you're coming around but I've
been on this 400 yeah and but I mean I
to the point like I had to erase all the
stuff that I was posting just cuz I was
just tired of just seeing negativity
like it just hurts it wears you out I
want to ask you this cuz I've been
reading a lot about let me go there's a
picture of stack so where he has the
Boyd's baby girl on the shoulder yeah
this isn't she says it's gonna change
the world
if that doesn't connect you hit you
where it hurts man mmm-hmm daddy things
the world that doesn't do something to
you all right
your sociopath yeah no it's right
let me ask you this man
I've been listening to a lot of black
scholars and reading you know Larry
elders Thomas Sol I listen to canna
sona's is is got some stuff to say for
sure she just shows employed she's just
so strong about rubes her point of view
that it's like but listen you know she's
I still think she's a valid voice and
one of the things I never [__] hear
CNN talk about and people talk about I
can't say anything but there are certain
issues within any community any
community in any culture that work then
and don't work now and if and one of the
things that Larry elders said which I
thought was kind of hit me and I was
like damn is he said in the 1960s a
black child was 80% likely to be born to
a two-parent household today it's
reversed legitimately and when that
happens when a child is born to a single
mother you have a 5% thought you're five
times more likely to be under the
poverty line you're nine times more
likely to end up in jail you're 20 times
more likely to mean the stats are so
[__] like I don't hear CNN and places
like that talking enough about that
which which as candice Owens Larry
elders Tom Saul said if you want to talk
about marchers these dumbass racists and
Charlotte's Feld you know they're always
there you know there that's what she
said that's a far less I'm Way less
worried about those dum-dums because
there are 25 of them there may be a
bunch but I'm more worried about that
situation later there and those are the
things that I think about and I go why
is nobody talk we got to talk about that
not because it's a criticism or just
because that makes sense to me you want
it's much easier to have to be you and I
have kids
we have kids about the same age you know
hum how much you have to rely on mom but
how much the kids rely on you but so at
the same time I'm a single dad but I'm
just very involved like I'm in my kids
lives in and I think you bring up a
great point for not only the black
community but community is all when
you're born to just one parent and
another parents not if all you're gonna
be behind that's a white problem too by
the way
got some sex all robbed and then people
want it quick too
say well there's you know the
black-on-black crime number majority
problem you interact with people in your
community so if your whole community is
black when you have commits ups and
communities and you kill each other it's
gonna be that the same thing in the
white community when you have mixed up
in the white community that's who you're
around us so you're gonna end up killing
Mexicans and so on and so forth but you
know there's definitely it goes to say
you know it's deeper like we're always
seeing the end result we're seeing the
killings and everything but it's it's
just it's obviously a deeper root we
dealing with the wreckage of our past
here right you know what I mean and like
you said for it for anyone for any black
people to think that we're getting
reparations is crazy paid they're not
handing a [__] you know we have to come
out with the plan to do it ourselves you
know and I think what we have is when we
unite and understand and have one voice
people understand we have the same
turnout in November that from the
minority community that there was when
Obama was elected president that Trump
will get blown out of the water and
people don't realize that you know what
I mean if we really come together and go
out there and vote that we can get Trump
out of the White House if that's what
people's goals are but like I said we've
just kind of always been on islands and
every United but is that the goal Matt
you think if you get Trump out so to me
the whole thing with me is you know ID
but I understand because people
understand the the ordinance of power
Trump the Obama Trump presidents don't
have that much power it's the Supreme
Court people don't understand that very
good point the presidents really like
when Trump says he's gonna do stuff
people kind of look crazy because if you
know he doesn't have that kind of power
you know people people still go crazy
but if you understand and study up he
can only do so much the president
they're not the most Mitch McConnell's
the most powerful man yes you know I
mean people don't understand how things
go so it's not so much that Trump is the
prosper like this is happening because
him I'm just from from a point of you
spew too much hate you can be you could
have been great you could use more
divided it's not you're a fire you can
be great at bringing the economy back
and doing things here and there but to
me I face so much races going up and I
think our that the state of our country
has built on hate so when you're someone
that won't come out and si say the
n-word or this or that but you
use dog whistle terms back in the day I
would knock them out or carry them on
the stretcher or the good old days like
to me your rhetoric is talking right to
those people they bit hate us right that
your your your dog whistling those
people so I don't care how great he's
been on any of the other fronts we just
need someone in that it's not gonna spew
hate you know we need every right so
we're more divided now than we've ever
been and it's unfortunate because you
don't with the black community or the
country in general the country in
general is divided the black community
is someone always been divided you know
means so that that's all you say it's
important to remember that when you say
black community look West Indian blacks
are very different than Nigerian blacks
are very different than ebo and yerba
bags are very different than then a
black guy a black family from
Mississippi that super religious is
believe me very different than a black
doctors family in New York it's very
different so that's why the the black
vote when people say that stuff and I
talked about this my last specialty
it's all over the [__] place if you
go to Africa daddy there's such a
difference between go tell somebody
who's Sudanese that he he's like
somebody who's from Ethiopia and they
border the same country good luck with
that how much there's a lot of even
there there's a lot of internal hate to
from all races but particularly some on
the black because we struggle with
colorism oh my god darker people don't
like lighters sometimes I say lighter
people think they're better than darker
and like at the in the day like we're
all first of all humid but we're all the
different color than you you had me so
why not any and when I say us it's even
you know there's tension between you
know uh you know Mexicans and blacks you
mean we're them we get treated the worse
so I'm a genetic okay we have a
consistent we come together let's try to
come together and sorry come together
and really fight the real enemy that's
fight racism to me it's everybody wears
racism because not all I'm half Italian
and black like I don't claim to combo
Harry I don't your mine was a time for
Italian you say you're facing a lot of
racism I'm sure can you get from both
sides right I was never wide enough and
I was never black enough
you know I mean
I was never dark enough and my hair
looked like this so you're not I get
from black people like what are you like
everyone thought I was Mexican for the
long girls hey girls tell me about hate
when you're 6-7 you were so good at
sport it was a little bit right that was
the brainer that's crazy you said it so
that was the only thing about how I got
accepted because I grew up and when I
when I lived in San Jose in Northern
California until I was about 8 and then
I moved to Sacramento I was
predominately round Mexican Asians in
blacks and even though I was half white
I was never really around my kids so
when I went moved to Sacramento at 8 or
9 my parents although we lived in a
similar neighborhood my parents put me
in white schools and I never understood
why so that was the first time I was
really around all white kids and I
remember when I went to third grade I
came to Sacramento in third grade and
like the first week in school they put
me down like in the kindergarten pod
like in the class to learn some stuff
and I'm just like there was such I
remember it now that's just like the
education was so much different I mean I
was in third grade and in a bad
neighborhood I went to a better school
and I they put me back in the
kindergarten you know my first time
classes so there was such a disparity
but the only thing that got me by
because I was never wide enough so then
I was always fighting kids that you know
I was getting [__] at an early age and
I used to hurt my feelings and I would
be sad and my dad's like if they call
you [__] fight him so that's what nine
years old that's what I remember still
so I was always fighting always fighting
but then once I whoop did enough kids
ass they finally gave me a chance like
and then I was good at football baseball
and basketball and so through sports is
what they gave me a chance to find out
who I really was know it wasn't just the
color of my skin or being Miss it was oh
man he's the best at foot boys the best
at basketball he hits home runs all the
time let's give this guy a chance and
then from that point I still have
friends from that age and some kids I
started trying to fight that I'm still
friends with this thing cuz they we
finally they got a chance to just look
at me as a person and not necessarily a
colored person hmm you know so it was
for me and then it came to a culmination
in in high school when there was them I
was a senior my sister was a sophomore
there was this rich kids whose dad was a
big lawyer in Sacramento and he was
calling my sister a [__] and I just
never happened to run into a lot I get
done with my fourth period which is my
last class of the day and my sister come
with her two little girlfriends comes
crying to me saying you know he
me [__] and spit my hair and she
pulled her hair out and show me and the
kid just happened to walk hi and I just
you know locked in on him beat him down
you know went back to the office the
school didn't believe what he did is
that's a prominent lawyer he doesn't
raise like this he wouldn't talk like
this la la ba ba ba
monster showed up suspended for a week
while I'm suspended the KKK like nearly
burns down my like burns down a building
on our campus in Sacramento yeah I saw
it and did they hang like hey hung a
noose or mannequin on a noose with my
football jersey on die [__] why Boston
goes everywhere broken windows life so I
faced a lot a lot of racism growing up
so I've always been quote unquote woke
or just sensitive to the topic because
like I faced real life racism you know
what I mean so just to me is it for all
the people who say look what Trump is
done in this and look what he's done
there and look what to me if you have
any hating you I just can't I can't
appreciate you know I can't respect you
I can't go with anything you're saying
because the world this the country is
built on hate and George Floyd was
killed because of hate yeah yeah we fear
what we don't know you know to in and
that's something that I'm talking with
some politicians about or you know some
bill makers about is with all the
funding that these police unions get we
need to start like these core programs
where you know you're trying to recruit
people from an inner city and because if
you come in a neighborhood I grew up you
hear a gunshot to you hear some you know
it's gonna frighten you yeah I'm used to
that [__] you know not necessarily
gunshots or whatever the situation may
be but I'm saying like when we grew up
in a community we're used to so-and-so
arguing down the street I know how to
deescalate that I'm used to hearing
gunshots sometimes cuz it happen so I'm
not gonna be in the ferry-landing
familiar but when you come into my
neighborhood you go into a black
neighborhood where you're not familiar
you're in being a cop is scary you say I
don't take nothing away from how
dangerous that job is but when you know
your community and you know people by
name and you know the kind of stuff that
goes on you're more susceptible to kind
of being cool calm and collected under
situations and only administrating force
when it really needs to be done because
you're accustomed to what's going on in
these neighborhoods and I think too
often we're putting people who have no
understanding of our culture in our
culture and we've had a history of these
people coming in our culture and already
kicking our ass and killing us and now
they're doing it with no penalty you
know what it means so there's always
gonna be some pushback you know I'm
surprised that it hasn't been more
people retaliating you know you never
want to see that right I'm just
surprised it has happened because it cuz
it's getting always said if people if
Americans spent just one month overseas
in another country like I lived in the
Middle East for eight years of my life
so when the Iraq war and stuff was
happening and I would hear people talk
about Arabs and it was always in in in a
way even if even if it wasn't like what
they would say that was you hear
educated people who'd never been
anywhere near the noise they would you
tear people who knew better and they
would say this I heard this probably a
dozen times they don't look at human
life the way we do and I I grew up there
so I've got news for you yeah they do
yeah they do in fact because their
communities and their villages are so
tight they are even more bonded you know
everybody you grew up with everybody
every generation so when someone dies
believe me Kevin Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
made a good point cuz he has this
business deal with Chase Bank and he was
in this meeting and they said well what
we want to do is we want to send these
represent these representatives from the
bank into these lower income schools in
these these black districts and
chemicals none of them can't do that he
goes they're not gonna relate to that he
was I grew up you know in the in the you
know the rough parts of Philly you need
to send so it looks like me or send me
because I can tell them why they
shouldn't go to that check cash place
when they get why there should be invest
of them why they should have an
education expand your house like but if
you bring in a white guy some rich white
guy the kids Mike we don't know that
coming in but you're gonna leave us
alone how to read the wheel they don't
wanna read the room that's right
I think that's 23 year old we don't
there but I also think you're such a
good voice representative voice for for
the for the culture for for what's going
on right now because I don't think a lot
of people know this is you know your dad
if you can speak on what you know what
you grew up with what your dad can get
for a profession I don't know if you
know this beep now cuz you've seen you
know with your mom the talent Whiteside
being a superstar in the NBA but also
you know you your dad kind of did the
the dark arts yeah I would say so you
I'm a tree so my dad Italian no my dad's
no black my mom's Italian the dark arts
yeah you know so my dad grew up and it's
getting older now you know my dad was
always there but we never got along
until my mom died at 27 because my dad
yeah my mom my cancer so my mom died
when I was 27 but my dad grew up in from
a tough you know a tough mom that was
really tough on him and made his life
hell so he never really grew up in love
so he never knew how to love so I grew
up in a drug-filled abusive household
you know where my parents were
functioning drug addicts
Bob yeah but my dad was just hardcore so
he was a butcher by night and butcher by
day and drug dealer by night you know
and I mean I might it was funny a little
quick story while we were little well my
dad would get off work you told used to
go make night runs to deliver drugs and
my brother's four years younger than me
so he didn't really get it I got it but
I was just so yeah you know grow but
seeing kit people do cocaine right in
front of me and all kind of [__]
my brother didn't really understand it
so when my dad would leave in nine my
pet my brother for the longest time
thought my dad was a ninja until he was
going out all black or black this is
where my dad was a ninja you know what I
mean good-looking do you know Tommy
no not about 510 so we just I grew up in
a very cheers boys cheers fellas thanks
for coming to a better world mm-hmm
I grew up in a like I said just a tough
household so eyes I learned my hard
knocks early on you know I learned a lot
of stuff fast saw a lot of stuff fast
and was almost forced to understand the
world fast you know I mean so I grew up
with drugs violence and abuse but then
as soon as you know and then the next
thing added on to was race you know I
mean once we moved to Sacramento I
didn't see any racism when I was in San
Jose early on because everyone looked
like me or were close to me we're in the
same neighborhoods and we were fine so
I'd be ribs all this childhood stuff and
then the next being thrown on top of me
was the race thing so I just always had
navigated and I've had an open mind from
a young from a young age because I've
had so much [__] come at me
you know I mean some when people saw the
basketball player I was where I would
fight in a heartbeat
I was physical it was just my that's how
I grew up you know I mean everything to
me was it was a survival of the fittest
because I wasn't I was a second round
pick I wasn't in LeBron or Katie you're
Kobe none of these guys I was someone
who had a scratch and claw to get my way
into the league and once I got I had to
scratch and claw to keep it you know
what I mean so I was always team yeah
you know me so you can you tell the
listeners and Brian like being draft in
the second round means nothing means the
odds of you making it even though he's
driving a semi not true hop high on the
top you know forty players in the world
college the chances of you making the
team as a second-round draft pick is not
good is that true absolutely most guys
go cuz you played for 14 seasons yeah no
it's not me first of all that I have an
average India career is only three years
so you know for me to be a you know uh I
think I was 46 pick in the second round
out of what 60 picks or something
there's two PS you thinking the chances
are very slim so I went in thinking
thinking like everyone else I played
card battle in the NBA that's why we are
ever you can't tell a college baseball
player that plays at a major school that
he's not going to the NBA and they're
gonna believe you like we don't like you
don't plan for nothing else but going to
leap but the harsh reality is is you're
not 1% of student athletes go pro Dallin
percent of students do this at Hughes
kids he played at UCLA when I was at
university Colorado which is a
powerhouse especially at the time
there's such a powerhouse for NFL draft
picks and we're all in the room and they
had NFL head coach here it who it was
he's talking to team egos let me ask you
guys a question here yes how many think
of you how many you think you're making
to the league stand up everybody stood
up he does not want everybody here to
sit down step for this guy in this guy
to guys because maybe these to the
rescue
focus on your studies man and he goes
and these two it'd be a stretch so it's
it's his fun you said if I'm doing 13 of
us made it but whatever but you got to
think about it too I mean you're going
to a powerhouse school you know most of
these schools aren't powerhouses so like
the numbers averaged out because you
guys had 13 so you guys are pretty much
for all the bad schools that's how're
you guys you know that means so I'm
working with high school kids now and
you can't tell none of these kids are
not going to the NBA so I'm trying to
teach these kids to understand being a
star in their role subducts dog river
used to teach us be a star the reason
why I last so long
because I knew my role I could play my
role any team I knew what what my
strengths were I could do more but it
wasn't what a team needed so that was my
ability to just know you're gonna play
defense you're gonna knock down threes
you're gonna rebound you're gonna be our
team protector all right I played 14
years I made a lot of money doing it but
I understood my role I think a lot of
these kids want to come in and everyone
thinks they can come in and be a Kobe or
come in and be a Kevin Durant or LeBron
James and those people are generational
talents and most people first of all
most people aren't gonna make it what's
the ratio 99.9 I could make it but
here's the thing
yeah you got a how many how many guests
are in team 12 for this 420 guys in the
NBA 430 guy how many her team though 12
some like that well 14 12 14 so if
you're a sec around African first night
you're taking some veteran spot well now
some guys are younger but at that time
ratio of how much of it is what so when
you see generational talents how much of
that is a physical difference and how
much of it is a mental different I think
90% of the game is mental
first and foremost but when you get
talent a lot of it like Kobe was
god-given talent I forgot he won the
slam dunk contest you're talking about
yeah so Katie was god-given talent
LeBron there's guys at a god-given
talent but god-given talent only get you
so far you have to apply that work ethic
and that's what makes good guys great
you know I mean cuz Kobe was a sicko
Mike was a sicko you know these guys
that are great are sick mentally from a
standpoint of they're gonna do anything
it takes like I loved basketball but
when I work with Kobe I worked at a
different level you know I mean like I
always wanted to work hard and I thought
I was always working hard but when I saw
his preparation and what he went through
thinking day after day night after night
rep after rep was like them I didn't do
as much during my career to be as you
know beat up cuz I didn't know his well
you don't pay the price right like I'm
sure you know and Michael Jordan talks
about this too like he wasn't around as
far as a dad that he wasn't there man
yeah he was he would his job was to be
the best basketball player that comes a
heavy toll man I might miss out on
birthdays what to me I I enjoyed the
ride you know what I mean I think
sometimes and I can't speak for a
superstar but I want to enjoy the ride I
don't want to be so locked into
something that I'm missing out on my
kids that I'm missing out on living that
I'm missing out on experiences with love
like
I don't want it some and this is not
anyone in particular but some guys get
so sick on being the greatest that that
takes a lot away from their that being
normal you know being human having fun
having these regular interactions and I
just I wanted to enjoy the process the
nano gamer I worked my ass off you can
never you watch one of my games you know
I played as hard as I could every time I
practice as hard as I thought every time
but I definitely enjoyed the ride yeah
you know what I mean and uh and you you
have you have Kobe over LeBron - I do I
think the broad can pass him to be
honest with you to me it's Mike Kobe
Bron and I think bran can pass them with
another win Bron Bron it's not a sicko
like that I brought know he's a
different kind of secret we've never
seen know what LeBron is a Magic Johnson
s yeah you know I mean but just what
bigger and more athletic but just a
different kind of star where there's
still the charisma and the fun and the
cool factor and all that kind of stuff
he might be physically the greatest
athlete to ever step on the court I
wouldn't doubt that I mean all around
Brazil Boozer was saying I'm same size
and he said he's you understand his
speed oh yeah yeah that's that extra
speed that's so crazy like a lightning a
droplet yeah without ever playing it
down I mean it fits but don't you I
think it to me whenever people talk
about the greatest of all time the
debate it's so it's almost silly because
the the competition that the basketball
game was different when Jordan played
yeah and if you want to talk about Oscar
Robinson you want to talk about these
other you know Pete Murray but you talk
about all these these old school guys
compared to now like what LeBrons doing
now it's just it's almost unfair right
and then also that like Kobe towards the
tail-end kinda like you but Michael
Jordan didn't deal with the social media
it was just a different time oh it's a
lot well if you look at it you know
that's why I was it's a difficult debate
because so many different genres a
basketball change like you look at the
Bob Cousy era with it the historical
Celtic teens where these guys are
grilling on the court with just one hand
yes like they can't even dribble with
their left hand and they're doing short
shot shots and all this kind of I see
more than seven white people on the
court I mean so when you look at you
know when Wilt Chamberlain put in this
is rest in peace obviously you don't
want it ever do minimum that minimizes
greatness but he's the average player
back then wasn't good the average player
had another job average clear yeah you
know that
players are smaller six to you maybe you
might have snuck that sound I wouldn't
even in the 50s guys lose e teams they
won't even the and a deal they will get
destroyed Roy like those those those uh
you know when if you put like the old
Celtic teams that want all those rings
against like Kobe and Shaq or against
him dummy Kevin McHale oh really I'm
talking with the older team they'll be
those eight to me when the 80s is really
kind of in it I was born in the 80s but
the 80s to me and the tail end of the
70s and 80s to me were to probably the
best era of basketball 80s and 90s when
that Magic Bird Jordan everything we
grew up on like to me that was the best
that was it was physical basketball you
had to be a man to play and you had to
earn everything there was no you know
today although I love the game and you
have to continue to evolve with the game
today it's just softest tissue you can't
touch no one you can't breathe on no one
it's all about scoring but at the same
time the game is bigger globally than
ever because people don't want to see it
you don't turn on the TV to see a 79 82
game you want to see Steph in the worst
go 130 you want to see LeBron do all
these dunks you want to see highlights
so you don't want to see the defensive
struggle you know in the peers of the
game want to see a defensive battle and
have some kind of you know something to
hang their hat on but it's just a
different game now you know so $10 it's
more scoring it's more about it and I
don't mind that because like you said
that continues to grow the game and and
out even someone who played I don't want
to turn on sports then and see like a
defensive battle I want to see some
highlights I want to see who got dunked
on how far away did Steph shoot the ball
like how many points did clay have like
I want to see the offensive side of it
so all games it's great point all games
have kind of evolved from then so it's
so hard to compare errors yeah it's
weird when people do that when they get
your fighters like you took a different
time different training just a different
atmosphere
whatever is nice maybe or no J and Jim
Brown would have been lifting weights
and training differently but the AB for
me it's like a mindset
I feel like extreme winners are extreme
winners regardless really you know I
mean you to your point depending what's
like put hoist grace in the UFC right
now
good luck hey you want to win a fight no
no it's just evolved but at the time you
know he's this goat cuz that time no
knew what was going on he had this
ground game and was like what the hell
you know yeah people caught up people
caught him I agree did you did you watch
the last dance doc mm-hmm how goddamn
good was incredible incredible the way
they were be able to that's gonna sweep
the Awards this year for the house to
dishonor but the ability to go back and
forth on the on the timeline so little
confusing right house it was yeah but to
me we never so MJ was the one superstar
that we'd mentioned earlier there was
never there was in social media and he
was the one guy you saw play sold shoes
and was the owner and that's it we never
saw nothing else from Mike we've heard
stories that's right so we got to see
the tail end of Kobe's crew we got to
see him open up on social media and show
who he is LeBron has been great at it
other stars we've been blessed and
people don't fans will understand how
fortunate they are because back in the
day we didn't get in none of this stuff
so you're so fortunate to be able to see
what these athletes lifes are and I
think instead of appreciating we want to
attack it but that's another subject but
we finally got to see this so to me the
last deck was on dance was almost like
social media for Michael Jordan but we
got to see the locker room we got to see
practice we got to see off the court him
in the hotel room you're right we got
you got do you think I'm not like you
know what yeah is that [__]
smoked wherever you want he smoked on
the plane he smoked he's smoking into
the hotel everywhere yes cigars
Thank You everywhere yeah but in the
locker room right after a game he's
smoking and drinking a bit like drinking
beers no problem but smoking anywhere
like I smoked weed all through my career
but I had to like barricade myself in my
room at hella candles incense put the
towel down cool yeah this dude is
walking into the lobby on the elevator
in the hotel lobby yeah you know
hallways just smoking it like there was
some stuff to me that like trip me up
but I just thought was so dope like he
doesn't give a [__] and I love it when
you watch that stuff that does it make
you miss basketball I don't miss the
locker room uh those are fun times but I
just like I said I enjoyed the ride and
realized how much of a sacrifice all
those a blessing that basketball was
that we had to make in our real life you
know to me like the reason why I retired
wanna no side
eight 14 years the year I retired I got
lucky and won a championship but I had
signed a 3-year deal that year and I
retired after the year because one we
won even though it didn't go down the
way I kind of ideally thought of it - I
wasn't gonna chance to see my kid I was
going through a bad divorce at the time
and then three businesses that I started
in my like 3132 I retired at 37 kind of
started turning so it was kind of a
perfect storm of you just want a
championship you're good with money your
other business is starting to turn like
let's go see what's next you know so I
kind of just stepped away to see what
was next because you know if you think
about it a basketball season is eight
months too long it's eight months and
then you've got to think we usually only
take three or four weeks off because you
can't get too far behind the 8-ball in
the summer so we're on 11 out of 12
months a year training to be the best
athlete in the world you know to be a
one-percenter you know for 20 years I
tried to eat right work my ass off and I
missed so much stuff and you don't
realize how much stuff you miss until
you're done so when I transition from
retirement you know from basketball to
retirement and started doing other
businesses and was able to coach my kids
and football and basketball and be there
every day for my youngest son I just
have such a just such a great
appreciation because there were so many
birthdays I missed and assemblies I
missed in all kinds of these family
situations and not being there for
friends and obviously we make a
sacrifice to do what we do and I
wouldn't change it for the world but you
know post-retirement I haven't missed
basketball all because it just took so
much time and it became a business at
the end and then the travel was horrible
like truck we just travel so much so it
was a blessing amazing time I wouldn't
change it for the world
you know the business stuff I'm doing is
obviously correlated to people knowing
me through basketball but I'm just I'm
at peace post-career a lot of guys
struggle because you know I kind of got
to walk away on my own terms you know a
lot of guys don't get to finish the way
they want to when it eats at them you
walked away with the championship but
also I think one of the reasons you're
so successful after is your so our
ticket you know like there's like you
know it is like there's a lot of guys
who literally do it all they could be
basketball you asking many other sorry
my own you know what's funny about that
was I take it back to my childhood when
I didn't understand it I don't even know
if they understood what they were doing
but my parents put me in white schools
so I talked different and I
different and the first time I read
dinner at a dinner table was with the
white family with my friends first time
I ever went on vacation was with my
white friends so I saw another side that
I would have never been privy to if I
would have just stayed and done stuff
with my family so when I look back I
used to hate it I used to cry like why
can't I go to school my friends God you
know you're gonna go to school here
there was no argument my dad I've just
mentally I'd argue you know but I just
never understood why why are you putting
me in these schools and now I'm so
thankful because I saw a different side
I know how to articulate I know just
life from a different side although I
was you know half Italian I didn't live
a white light and we didn't have money
we had food stamps there was drugs there
was moving there was a bunch of people
in one room like I didn't have a normal
quote/unquote white upbringing you know
so to be able to see that and understand
that so that's why I said I am so
sensitive to race because I see there's
a lot of good white people out there a
lot ago I think more obviously more good
white people than bad of course but I
finally I got a chance to see the best
in the end the best and the worst from
both sides you know so to me it's just
the hate is is something that has
plagued this country from the beginning
and I think for once you know we're
turning a corner but I hate is a tought
thing you know I talked to my twins when
this stuff was going on with George
Floyd I'm just very open with him about
everything we've talked about cannabis
we've talked about women we just talked
about everything I want to have a open
line of communication with them so they
don't feel like they have to hide
anything and you know we were briefly
talking about it and I asked him I was
like you know his is what do you think
about the situation you know a white cop
killed another black guy another black
guy for no reason and it's happened a
lot how does it mean hurts my feelings
it's sad it's like he's scared and know
that I know we're not scared but then I
asked him was just like is hate are you
born to hate are you taught to hate and
then kind of stopped them thought for a
second and like you're taught I'm like
right so just like you could teach to
love like you could you know you can
teach love like right so we had their
little brother's asking him 17 months on
one of the twins like well didn't we
have to teach Ashton to love and I liked
it almost made me cry because it's that
simple like hate is a taught trait
correct like you teach you would
whatever you pump your
get full of it mentally is what they're
gonna turn out to be and it's
unfortunate that because you asked most
white people that claim may hate black
people or a part of the cake and why
don't you like black people weren't you
like Mexicans they're gonna give you a
generic stereotype answer right you know
by the way but I could really cracks me
up as a lot of peel back I'm not racist
I'm just Pro white if you've listened to
those guys with your heart but I mean
even in their own mind they're trying to
justify the fact that they aren't wrong
and and I think a lot of times to your
point from before you're taught to hate
fear can sometimes human beings can fear
the unknown fear Scotland to love first
and foremost yeah you're so much
stronger than me so when you align for
Broncos would you rather fear your love
you said fear yeah and when you and
since fear is something human then
wonder even do you go ahead yeah so so
getting people you know involved with
each other is really important it's so
important once you do that did you find
out do you think there's racism in the
NBA I felt that you know it's a little
different but an NBA you think I
wouldn't call it racism I call a biased
an equal-opportunity I was I would did
get up this morning and I had a thirty
teams or seven black head coaches and
there's five black general managers yeah
she just meant to play devil's advocate
are there that many candidates though
there are the white there are there are
then they're just not really good I mean
the fact that they had to put the Rooney
rule in the NFL which means you have to
hire one minority candidate for an open
management position in 1993 the fact
that they had to implement that rule
should tell you that their train of
thought like you're not giving these
people an equal opportunity to be and I
use this analogy as well in a child
ninety-three percent white what would
happen or fans or players or what would
people think if I mean that thirty I
don't know how many hockey teams are if
twenty out of the thirty hockey teams
were coached by black guys if they'd be
a problem if twenty general managers
were black in hockey like that's a
predominantly white sport there would be
so that people I wouldn't matter it
would matter it would never be some kick
back you know it means so for the NBA to
be 75 percent black for the NFL to be 68
percent black we're just not represented
like we're well we'll pay you money and
you're good to entertain us but we don't
want you making any kind of decisions
you know what I mean and to me we're
able to do both
is that in the NBA to though would you
that the NBA 75% black that's it the NFL
is 68 percent black there's a huge
influx of European I don't know what the
percentage of white players you can
google it I don't know what the
percentage of white players in the NBA
are towards your butt but it's more than
white there's more European that's why
I'm saying like you know how the tunnel
yeah okay the others no yeah JJ reddick
kind of hold it for real there's a
handful of I got there yeah you know I
mean but yeah there's a 23% white as oh
yeah yeah also there is more white guys
than your I wonder if they're counting
European out see when they say twenty
three percent that's European has their
opinion yes I agree with that you know
so just to me and you hire people who
look like you you know what I mean so it
starts at the top you know what my
friend
yeah people you look like and that's not
in sports that's just in life you know
what I mean so until people start you
know tomorrow - it's like you can see
that when a white comic performs for a
lot of black people in the audience the
difference between your if you start
hitting a large let's just say a regular
black audience if you start hitting them
with esoteric [__] sometimes they're
like listen dude that's not my reality
the [__] do you do in Canada that's all
weird and quirky is I'm dealing with
real-life issues it's just a fact like
I've been doing this for too long there
is something about a black audience that
is dealing on the whole in this way you
see a real difference as you can do an
anthropological study they're dealing
with things like bills they're dealing
with things like credit things that are
real to them where they live so if you
come at them with your perspective and
it's only been white you're not gonna
get last it's not that they're being
rude it's just that it doesn't resonate
you have a chance to be in their shoes
yes because you got think a lot of and
not just black I say minorities are
surviving they're not living that's you
know I mean so when you're when you're
surviving every day I'm trying to
survive like I'm living
you mean I'm comfortable working my ass
off to where I'm living every day and
enjoying it although there's some tough
times but there's some people that are
surviving everyday you know so come but
but it's in Democrats to crack my lip
let's say liberals and service here's my
impression
of conservatives the whole [__] place
is going crazy and my the average
conservative goes what the [__] what
are these people
relax we've put it all these things in
place I mean and then liberals like
super liberals are totally hysterical we
know it's all right they so they're both
there's just disconnected man yeah where
is all I do is I go all that [__] that's
going on right now like all that [__]
something's wrong right they're not that
anger doesn't just come out of nowhere
there's no question I know the other
thing it correct me if I'm tell me about
what you think of this cuz when I have
conversations with black men about race
about all kinds of stuff you know what I
find is really interesting and maybe
it's cuz I'm white and I'm asking a lot
of black men because their men are macho
and men don't like to complain and men
don't like to say somebody else's is the
problem so I'll get vague general kind
of like things when we're on the road in
Houston you know I've been a advocate of
how you think this Coronas [__] and
it will stuff like then I speaks facts
and I have all my stats to back it up
and our friend Malik who's a black dude
he's that I'm like I'm speaking my
features I'm telling these people and he
open up for us in Houston and then Brian
say let me talk to her what dude he goes
his grandfather's passed away from
Corona yeah but I think to get back to
your point I think as like I told you my
upbringing and I'm sure there's people
who had similar upbringing is there in
the black community or minority
community or and people had were so from
an early age we're taught to be men
early yeah I mean so we see a lot more
house so you know inflated so
insecurities complaining crying feeling
bad for your son like what like what I
told you when I was sad laugh like why
are these white kids all called me
[__] why won't they play with me my
dad didn't hug me and say it's gonna be
a race I'd fight these [__]
yeah I mean so we're taught early on to
not show weakness you don't want to show
see any kind of sign a weakness you know
I mean so I love the fact that mental
health is talked about now you know I
mean and not just black white white up
men is a masculine thing our egos are
big we're masculine were prideful were
raw
were to be a man is to be a man you know
what I mean so to show any kind of
vulnerability no matter what race or
nationality or belief you have is is
somewhat considered weak this is
unfortunate it's a stereotype you know
so to me now that people are talking
about I have a new show coming out that
we've created that basketball is a
backdrop but the main thing is the
mental health of an athlete and how the
streets kind of play into the whole you
know the the whole play of being
professional athlete and me and
successful athlete but the mental health
aspect is huge in this something that we
don't talk about it's always been like
you know something that was looked at as
weak but it's important because you know
we are a product of our environment you
know so there's a lot of in with me you
know what I mean I haven't had
successful adult relationships you know
I've was with my twins mom for seven and
a half years and I divorced her and then
I was just with my last kids mom for two
years but I grew up I'm no brother yeah
I wonder when people go I didn't work
out dude seven years ago uh-huh
but I got divorces like papa that's what
I'm saying at the same time what I was
trying to say was I wasn't brought up in
a household bit mom showed me how to
treat a woman showed me how as a man how
to love so that's why as a father now I
try to be a super dad try to do
everything that my dad didn't do and
although my dad and I are great today
like my mom died in 2007 when I was 27 I
wish the ninja was in here oh yeah he
cried and for the first time he cried
and apologized and tell us a little bit
about his upbringing letter
understanding so to this day my dad and
I are amazing I'm 40 now so for 13 years
he's been an amazing dad and to me it's
never too late to be a dad do you know
what I was thinking about watching watch
the nose you thing and they had that
section on the police and what it was
like to be black and Watson black in Los
Angeles because there's a huge migration
here and black people found jobs here
there were jobs that the economy
absorbed a lot of black labor and
skilled labor and and a lot of black
people became educated here for a while
for a while in Los Angeles it wasn't a
bad place in see most people left the
South came north and are came came West
West and it was it was a really a land
of promise you could own your own house
it was a [__] big deal and then I
watched then I watched these the imagery
and the video of these cops doing what
they were doing to men and women
and and how and and one of the guy said
99% of black people if you asked him
they would have said they would have
felt the same way they would they were
angry that they would said that they
would have agreed with that feeling this
guy was talking about being treated that
way and 1% are really angry so and what
I thought to myself is a man and I
watched hist as I thought [__] men that
would wear on me emotionally and it
would wear on my spirit it would almost
get you see we don't talk about that
like a lot of times when you're told
over and over again that you're not
capable when you're told over and over
again you don't have the same potential
what happens poll after poll when they
pull black men quietly
and nobody's listening you're battling
with about feeling of self belief of the
idea of maybe I'm not as capable that's
the real life though yeah so when you're
constantly under assault like that and I
also say this for I know there are what
there are a lot of people listening I
know this is happening right now I know
there's a lot of push back I know that
yes we voted for a black president yes a
lot of white people are not prejudiced
yes there's been a lot of work done to
equal the playing field for white people
but you have to know this I'm just
telling you this and I'm not a liberal
I'm not a [__] liberal I'm not I'm
not a Bernie supporter or any of that
[__] so I'm telling you this as somebody
who's read a lot about history of the
history major and I've read right down
the pipe killer right but I'm saying
right down the pipe what I say as
somebody who's read a fuckload of
history and taken a lot of courses after
college on history okay and I'll give
you the aisle right at them no I was
always shocked I'm always shocked and I
said it over and over again at how how
how at the ferocity and consistency of
the assault on African Americans it was
it was a constant assault from where
redlining to starving areas of resources
and stuff that's just a historical fact
that that I pick up in Israel you'll
understand when you see that you can't
help but just be kind of overwhelmed
with how every time there was a
renaissance Harlem had a renaissance in
the 20s if you look at video of Harlem
and twenties watch you see well-dressed
black educated black Wall Street bro
black Wall Street Wall Street was
businesses and then those areas were too
apparently starved of resources and
deliberately destroyed I'm said that is
a fact and that's in the 20th century I
think it's a thing to with power you
know what I mean this is a with all due
respect like I said I'm not racist but I
just understand and I'm looked at as a
blight this has been a white man's world
you know what I mean and they've done
everything they possibly can - first of
all and foremost stop blacks but then
minorities as a whole but through all
the pitfalls and [__] they've tried to
put us through we keep jumping out yeah
keep rising yeah you know what I mean
okay so now the only thing they can do
is kill us yeah you know what I mean to
me and it could crazy sounds you want to
kill a black man become a police officer
that's the only way you can kill a black
man for free and get off and it's sad to
say that and when I say that is not all
bad cops because all not all bad not all
cops are bad the majority are you'd be
an idiot to say all cops are bad but to
me what separates a good cop to a bad
cop because I don't genuinely believe
all cops have intention based off race
went out to me I think what I can label
some bad cop says is not standing up
when you see your partner doing some
racist [__] you know mean like that
video right you're sighs okay your side
yeah your silence makes you bad like you
we used to be okay with you know we used
to give people a pass well he doesn't
understand because he's not black that
used to be a pass I used to be something
that's a but now it to me what like you
said just to be able to educate yourself
and understand strange history and
people want to say well that was my
answer so that's not me but we still
want you to understand what your
ancestors it's not you have to
understand it has that [__] has residue
it has echo it has ripple it has an
effect you you're talking about
communities that were like are dealing
with very little to start out well what
do I mean what what what would the world
do if all these black killings of late
were flipped what if it was black cops
killing a white kid jog man can I can I
ask you this and please educate me on
this cuz we've had this discussion some
of my friends and they go yeah but if in
again I'm a stat guy but this is deeper
than stats because if you look at the
stats into that 19 more
unarmed white guys were killed by police
officers than black guys but but people
I thought there's three times more white
Americans than there are black America
but but if you
if you go off per capita but let's let's
actually look at this better example can
you help me form a argument for that you
know I'm saying well you're saying
there's more white people so there's
more white people so they're gonna have
more on odd you know if you're gonna go
percentages cops are gonna run into more
white people than they do black people
because there's more white people you
know what I mean so it it's not even up
you can bring race in and out of it to
me it's good and bad you mean there's
good I feel like and you've been at the
top of your game like I fit in
professional athletes and cops like
there's a thing that that getting power
drunk you know I mean when I'm when I'm
a top NBA player making millions of
dollars a year I feel like [__] doesn't
apply to me rules don't apply to me I
can do what I want when you're one of
the best fighters in the world
[__] I just well I can make
twenty million I'm the heavyweight UFC
champion of the world like yeah certain
rules don't apply to 20 million beats so
I feel so I feel like cops are the same
way
you know they have this badge where I
can do and enforce and do all this kind
of stuff and they just get power drunk
instead of kind of doing the right thing
it's that great anybody funding them
though we're gonna get worst cop no I
get the good did you talk when you talk
about $150,000,000 I promise you I
promise you'll be okay their budgets
over I mean they're still there's a
billion in that in that you know we
should also say you know without I want
to say without going bad and I'm but I
want a caveat it so you have this re
more speak up them yeah you have this
caveat so but I'm gonna caveat riservato
but we should say that policing since
2015 and there's a caveat to this has
gotten better you hear this a lot people
say 2015 over a hundred unarmed black
men killed 2009 and 19 you're trying to
kill her oh yeah I don't play around
I just wanna you know he's gonna be
drunk you're Japanese trying to kill me
that's right but whiskey on the plane
2015 you'll hear the stat over 100 armed
armed unarmed black [__] killed in 2019
only nine that's a big good job lettuce
improvements right let's let's give a
shout out however what I was sayin what
I was trying to say about that is that's
that's true and that's to to the credit
of City Council's Police Department's
everything else however that the George
Hjorth Boyd thing was the final cherry
it
you're not talking about the last four
years you're talking about four hundred
oh yeah it's very important that in
kinda like you said so it's good but
it's not good enough no just to
understand history if you read history
you'll be more compassionate it doesn't
mean you're gonna be more liberal gonna
be more clear when people like you know
what I got a call from the LA Lakers
from Rob pálinka you know and a half of
his self in Jeanne bus and they just
asked me know how can the Lakers meet
make a meaningful impact during this
movement and it kind of drew me back you
know I mean cuz I kind of feel like some
and like I said this is just my thinking
and I love everybody I feel like some
white people feel like what do I need to
do to let let everyone know I'm down
with the movement what can I do to help
or what can I do yeah you know so when I
when I when I sat back and told him like
man that's a loaded question I'm about
to hop out of zoom but let me smoke and
give me till the end of day and I'll
shoot you back some some ideas so I hit
it back first and foremost and I was
just like this can't be a PR stunt this
can't be a let me throw a band-aid over
a knife now I'm like hey [__]
they know it's going you know like
really like with the Lakers being where
the Lakers are you can set a president
you know you could start a fund you can
you can you know you can let go of the
LAPD you know that's what a lot of
people there's there's certain things
you can do you can mentor a black child
with no parents whatever I mean but
whatever you do just like make it
serious because you can you know I mean
the Lakers are one of the greatest diner
franchises in the history of sports so
you set a president not only for the NBA
but for other sports franchises to
really try to get involved like I think
it's crazy that you haven't really heard
any of the NFL owner speak out on this
you haven't really heard too many of the
NCAA coaches football or basketball
speak up on this and you think who
drives revenue in both those sports
young black men you know what I mean so
you really haven't had how these these
obviously you know these NFL owners it's
this is mostly this not they're
obviously their main business but what
makes their business boom is black play
killer my killer Mike said what is this
is this fair man I think and I think a
lot of them you know like Drew Brees
came out and he thought he was fighting
the good fight and he [__] he loved
one word but he thought he was saying
the right thing and then he gets
attacked I'm out
probably the best guy in the NFL who
goes back to New Orleans in handy there
yeah more so than anyone yeah so I think
a lot of it speaking out are scarier
because it goes your racist
oh yeah to me I want you to speak from
the heart when Drew Brees initial I've
always been a fan of Drew Brees don't
know him but always been a fan when he
has initially came out I thought it was
very tone-deaf in bad timing and I was I
said some [__] that I that I said just
being me
what do you fire off on Twitter yeah and
then he and then he came back and kind
of gave a half-assed apology and I
thought that was just because he would
their people in front of his house am
[__] Drew Brees you know but when he
says Adam Jenkins right but someone but
when he sat down and really gave a
heartfelt apology to me you have to
under like because his track record has
been incredible for not giving back to
the community and doing this yeah being
a great guy but you know as the black
community we want people to understand
our point of view and we want people to
change so if so if Drew Brees thought
initially that the need was messed up
which he thought it was but then at some
point he ended up me and blah blah Diaz
goes back and forth but we won't change
we want people to be open to change and
understand it just with your own eyes
just see what's going on kid killer Mike
said something I thought was really
interesting I love that [__] he's at
least I went down that rabbit hole cuz
I've been very until he made that speech
I feel like I learned so much every time
I hear him talk correct and I'm
listening to him and and he said he they
said the same thing what can we do is
you know white people and so ladies I
mean I'd love to see some people take
there are a lot of kids that that don't
have parents that need parents in that
need help and and and mentor that child
figure out a way now we're all so
[__] busy mm-hm everybody's so
goddamn busy but if you really wanted to
get down to brass tacks there are kids
out there that could use a big brother
big system there are kids that could
really use guidance there are kids who
could could use that to me it's about
education yeah mom so my family did the
Big Sister program this isn't gonna
shine a good light on we got the same
girl this girls are real mad she came to
the house and I was like oh hell no uses
you was there friendlies you should work
I'm beat
I'll just say thank you easy for them
yeah yeah but way to go no she's 13 but
I think when white people ask like what
can you do I think the biggest thing now
is just you know obviously educating
yourself but calling out racism you know
I mean to embarrassment people getting
fired all that kind of stuff has to
continue happen like the black worried
Matt that that I worry that when you
find somebody who makes a mistake and
isn't racist you know you find somebody
who's who says something insensitive did
you buy Drew Brees shouldn't losses I
don't want them because that that what
happens is that's a reaction all of a
sudden people go under seizure
why are you are scared but but but you
have to understand I mean it's you're
you can educate yourself about
everything right here yeah two minutes a
day right one minute you know you look
so so to me there's no excuse for an
ignorant comment at this point anymore
you know what I mean we've always given
passes they don't live our lives they
don't understand this that's it's okay
it's not it's finally for the first time
ever it's not okay to be ignorant or
oblivious to our struggles but there are
arguments right so there are there are
scholarly arguments that may seem
insensitive but let me give you an
example when ben shapiro who's a
conservative will say i don't think it's
about raising things about culture
that's a point of view and and and and
people might find the fence you see a
lot of black people go you hate you
don't know what the you don't know what
people go through but but bench peer
will mount a very strong argument of non
as an on rate he's an Orthodox Jew he's
suffered is you know whatever the case
is i we have to have we have to we have
to allow room in the public debate to
have these debates and have these
conversations that will be uncomfortable
because that's how you move things only
being people outside understand like the
only way with grow that you never grow
when you're comfortable you never you
never grow in your comfort I think
that's a positive I think so I really do
at twenty twenty first of all has been a
[__] the worst year ever it has it's the
worst episode of all time I mean you
know I wanna start you know starting
with Kobe it's been a domino effect of
not bad things but horrible thing Kobe
passed away when January 26 my birthday
you know what I mean huh so it's been
that it's been this pandemic and then
it's
you know the biggest virus we've had
that we haven't actually found a cure
for has been race so it's been one thing
in effort or another so it's just been
such a hard thing to swallow but I
really feel like you know they say it
the Sun that the Sun wouldn't feel so
good if it wasn't for the rain like it's
been pouring on the world you know
particularly the United States so I
really feel like something good has come
out of this it's gonna come out of this
but one thing you can say you know if
you whether you want to point out the
looting the riding the protest whatever
you it's been all racists you know and
we're all together on Sunday a hundred
thousand people have you seen laughs and
that annoys me a little bit and
embarrasses me a little bit its first of
all white celebrities just can't wait to
[__] virtue signature I'm not even
working until every black like alright
dude we get it you're not regular thing
but then but then white people I feel
like in the protests are trying to help
do it's almost like [__] showing that
show how we just we just want the
support you know in an open-minded
understanding you know I mean just have
an open mind and just understand before
like I said before I've said a few it's
been ok before to not understand where
we're coming from but now it's not you
know and you have to edge it we even in
as a blue the black I mean do we have to
but there's so much we have to learn
there's so much we have to do moving
forward like I said for the first time
in 400 years they hear us you can say
you know Pino Mar the the first lady
tweeted the other day you know something
about you know I don't agree with the
rioting and the looting this is an
anniversary speech and it right and then
someone said well you know cap cap tried
to take a knee in your husband called
him a son of a [__] you know I mean so
we've tried there's never a right way in
white people's eyes for blacks to
protest and I love the way what was the
football player I said cap took a knee
and that was how we were asking Malcolm
Jay health he says yeah we're a team
peacefully peacefully peacefully for
quietly but that was that was the best
way to do it Matt in your eyes and me
the knee I think is that the best time
to do it because I think you know
there's a lot of cameras on us during
the national anthem you know so I the
the movement was hijacked by the
president and and say what you want the
NFL owners a good old boys club and if
you
understand with the good-old-boy Club
you know what that is they're all really
riders one minority yes right so he's
you know so they hijacked a peaceful
movement saying that you're
disrespecting the flag in the country
and it was never about that we were just
we use the the moment that the anthem as
our vehicle of protest you know we took
a knee at that time because we knew
cameras the order cap to new camera by
the way the point was that it was
controversial
it's supposed to be contrary it was
peaceful and it was quiet it was but you
know what it was is a lot of Americans
didn't see it as bringing light to
police brutality they saw this
disrespecting the flag so let's say you
own a team or you're Roger Goodell
ratings went down 20% mm-hmm now you tie
my bottom dollar so that so then what do
you do like if you're calling cabinet
because you have went hey dude instead
of taking a knee because we know the
message in the disrespect to the flag
but for whatever reason a lot of
America's [__] stupid they find that
this Retton they're not tuned in we're
down 3% could you have written all the
name no no no no no beaten to me all the
20% that went down I want you to educate
yourself understand why he's taken 20
you can't those 20 percent they're not
they're more than [__] them right the
point I get into me where I knew I just
can't say [__] but I solidified my
thinking when when I started seeing
veterans say we understand why cap is
kneeling I don't feel disrespecting this
was all colors all right I think all of
us if with a brain realized it wasn't
disrespect the right like that it was
about police brutality but then you have
the other what a president hijacked the
president did his dog was something he
hijacked to call them all son of a
[__] and people are there's so that
the problem is there such as so many
followers in this won't come cheap
yeah there's not enough leaders and in
and you know individual thinkers you
know so that president hijacks the
movement and everyone jumps on the train
and it went away from what it was in
about president Allah Titian never
underestimate
never underestimate the virtue for
Americans is something called sacredness
there are certain things that are sacred
to a middle folks you find with the flag
the explaining so that so it's the same
thing it's like cutting up the American
flag to clean and to clean your bathroom
to clean your toilet to
has arrived for your toilet it may not
be legal it may not be illegal but for
Americans or Isis it is yeah
having having a few take a battleground
where a sacred battleground or something
that's part of American history they do
always studies people go so we have a
deep sense of what's sacred and what's
not but we pick and choose though
because Budweiser throws the flag you're
not supposed to wear the flag on a
t-shirt you're not supposed to wear the
flag in a bunch of different ways but we
pick and choose but you are it because
this America because the great thing
about the flag is says I can burn the
flag if I want and that's when you might
beat up yes but that's the strength of
this country that is the great strength
that the idea that you can do remember
you have the right to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
think about how general that is think
about it for a second you're not you
have the right to happiness for you have
the right to happiness right and then
and that was the point is that maximum
freedom was was allotted you have Ohio
certain without true but what's
beautiful about the time fathers now
remember when they wrote it to that's
what's the great irony of the great
experiment in Marion is that stasis that
they wrote the Constitution men who
owned slaves men who were racist they
wrote the Constitution what's beautiful
about the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights though is that very document and
that Bill of Rights and the thinking
that went around gave birth to feminism
humanism racism the notion of racism so
doctrine and that doctrine and those
principles were used to emancipate
emancipate people worldwide because you
can't argue with you guys say pians by
you val Harare about yeah no I mean I
obviously haven't done as much research
as you so I would never claim to know as
much but to me when you have stuff like
you said that the Constitution was
written by slave owners policing was
started as slave Wranglers I mean so we
need look at those two things they found
ever
policing was also used as as a way to
resolve conflict the courts were but
remember there is always criminals in a
society you you are gonna have murder
criminals don't have a color
dad dad doesn't have a color you know I
mean so you do need a police force for
the I don't agree with completely does
the one per so police like
Sumalee that's too many people that are
just bad people to live like that you
know how that help well that's gonna
help if you go no police or lords
gangsters well it's correct but also the
people that are gonna suffer are those
people the minorities yeah the rich
people can hire private security we're
gonna be fine
that's talked to south and I say where
were you and is that what would you give
Kaepernick a job because I think the
Seattle Seahawks trying out bring him on
the team it's tough man you sure
Seattle's gonna Bremen cuz here's the
other question if Russell Wilson did it
they're gonna listen a little more I
think the timing of cap doing it I think
if this was super cap Super Bowl run
when he was the most explosive dynamic
quarterback on the planet it went but a
lot of people had their first thing was
well he wasn't playing no more he was
this time his way mahomes does it that
was right well I mean I think I don't
know who started that video but Patrick
mahomes was on in the next day Roger
Goodell responds with you know a written
statement was passion mahomes it was
that the Jags are running back say Quan
Barkley from the Giants young was Lamar
Jackson they're the face League and they
sent you do you know this now they sent
Roger Goodell video saying you better do
some the next day on it this fool was on
FaceTime with everybody I would have
respected Roger Goodell so much more if
he would have said he said the NFL made
a mistake you should have apologized to
Kaepernick yeah why yeah I would to me
Rodriguez Oh Goodell would have went so
much and you know I don't know I think
he was gonna go down in history yeah as
as a positive figure in this he is gonna
be known more for his neve in his actual
playing like he's if he would have just
plays it he would have made a good
football player he's gonna go down as a
historical figure for what he started
and this is one thing i want to touch on
to us the knee like the need to me
doesn't mean very much anymore now
because you see one day you see cops
taking a knee but then later on TV we'll
see cops when people's answer to
peaceful protests like the knees been
hijacked now - now the NFL wants to
allow or if you want to need now you did
like that's [__] she loves exactly
even more years ago you blackballed
for peacefully taking an e4 Police
Battalion not to disrespect the flag not
to disrespect any race nation creed
color he wasn't doing he took a knee to
bring attention to police brutality to
minorities I'm not sure what happened
think about this think about how they
handled this think about this doing this
in and when the league starts up which
don't miss any games is me crowd think
if they did this today in this culture
they made guys who take any stay in the
locker room can you give me can you give
me a refresher course when when cap took
the knee I remember being controversial
what happened to him as a player did
they suspend him nothing nothing so he
can tell the time but he was blackballed
and then yeah and then you can shed some
but then I didn't last year remember
that guy were Guinean we're gonna give
him opportunity he was this is such
[__] figure we're gonna give you an
opportunity we're gonna have 20 scouts
there we're doing Atlanta Atlanta
Falcons headquarters so he gets it and
they hand him a contract we gotta sign
this they say what we didn't agree to
this my lawyers have listed over this is
something new out of I'm here to the
fine print base he's saying you can't
sue us down the road whenever happens
basically taking away all his rights
that if he was shunned from the league
kitchens even super you know God knows
how much money but if he signed that
contract all that goes so that's why he
did a private workout at a different
place yes last minute he said he balls
out so then yeah he played whatever
because it gave him a chance and you did
this and he was wearing a t-shirt that
had a fist I went yeah I did but also
jay-z went bad on cuz jay-z did people
out people don't know this jay-z's an
advocate for the NFL he's their liaison
now he's kind of like you for the NFL
right how you are there be another like
I don't know if Jay went bad on him I
think he's disappointed I don't I think
the only thing that that I might miss
with him when he said disappointed Jay
said we're past taking a knee I think
that's what pissed everyone off with
jay-z he were past taking a knee and
that's where the black community was
really kind of bothered by what he said
but I give jay-z pross because to me we
can't change nothing from the outside
like we finally have someone who's for
us that has a seat at that table there's
a that is a 99.9 percent white table but
we have someone that speak
they came from our culture that has our
background that has our DNA in us that
he that has enough power now to possibly
change things so
jay-z and the one thing you know
everyone always wants to know what are
you doing with like J move [__] behind
the needle you know where's so much
about self-promotion like look what I
did a protest let me enhance pictures
and show people and it's like to me that
I mean that's a whole nother stuff but I
think some people are just doing it to
put on Instagram to show but you know
jay-z is someone who is behind the
scenes pushing buttons calling I don't
even want to make a mistake of who we
called I think he called the governor of
Minnesota or some higher up ranking a
Minnesota like these police need to be
the other three police need to be
arrested and I think the day after they
were arrested you know I mean so Jay is
moving stuff for our culture he's just
not self promoting so I think he says
that right who else like this takes a
lot of [__] have you ever realized that
Kanye West is done know how many
people's college education he's paid for
funds that he started you know but like
I said I think where the black culture
lost Kanye was because he was supporting
someone who spewed hate like I said
Trump kind of could cost or make him a
pariah like because you have to
understand like if he if if if you know
Kanye growing in from the beginning he
was always it wasn't so much Pro black
it was just for the betterment of our
movements our you know I mean our he was
so much for our people and he was a
voice of our people and he's gonna go
down as one of the greatest minds he's
gonna go as I've horse historical figure
you know to me but I think the fact that
he teamed up with Trump when us who pay
attention and all we want is love and
peace although it's not ideal when you
when you team up with someone who
projects so much hate the the black
community is gonna turn their back he
was off the net then too though we got
to take that in account can also come on
your camera oh really
but then I just saw something that says
Kanye was just doing that to get people
out of jail
that's the only reason why he was got a
lot of and I'm not soft I love what
they've like I said outside of
supporting Trump and I don't even know
if Kim supports Trump I don't want to
talk like I know them cuz I really don't
I know man passing Kim has done her
thing she's been on that platform and
got people out and done other people I
don't know obviously Kanye helps that
movement there are very powerful couple
so I'm still
I'm still I'm still keeping the door
craft for Kanye to come back in and be
the guy that put out college dropout in
2000 do you want you want the Kanye that
this is Kanye's so Nike released a
collab with Kanye the red Octobers they
got the best shoe of all that it's the
whole array of shoes
bring it on you're not gonna like it you
couldn't wear what but the greatest do
the Holy Grail
but no one could get them the hardest
shoe to get some time ago hold up I was
you see what I'm wearing I'm not even a
shoe guy but those are some mats like
this he looks like what Kanye did he
went hold on I want my shoe for the
people guys can't kids can't buy these
so that's one of the reasons he left
Nike went to adidas and now his shoes
instead of releasing whatever they did a
500 pairs join pairs they released
thousands of thousands of years anybody
can really get them that you have to
wait in line that kind of kills the
allure though no because it makes it
cool but now kids can get them at these
kids in like now how many did they
release are those it was like 15 15 15
15 grand all right guys we sell does
buying I think you know we're keeping
that we're keeping the light on what was
that commercial we're keeping the light
on for him we're keeping the door craft
for Kanye because I said he can be such
a powerful like yeah you know and this
is on a different subject but we need
allies like I called Stephen a Smith out
on the wheat [__] he was always stay off
the weed and I called him out you know
me I'm just like you don't know what
you're talking about in your platform is
so big that if you understood what it
was about why we smoking how beneficial
it was you can be a real advocate for us
so through that he came on our show I
went on first take and you got think I'm
an ex-athlete
on first take the biggest sport show in
the world for 15 minutes talking about
weed in athletes yeah you know educate
in educating them on it you know
means up to me we need we need those
kind of allies because people with a
platform it's you know it's whether you
like a Chinese mind it will sink of rage
you know our close friend think of the
mines Joe Rogan changes through weed or
whatever it is diets how we lifestyle
whatever whatever it is he it moves in
waves or Joe is I mean I don't know how
much I agree with Oprah right now the
jury's still out on her but to me Joe is
has a movement of an Oprah know how
Oprah's move it was also strong through
the nineties when Oprah said we're not
eating meat stocks dropped and I like
Joe has that kind of power now so Joe
was a very important person you're here
Trump that video trouble he's a young
man I'll send it to you and they said
who would you like as your vice
president he said I think Oprah I think
she's a brilliant woman I think she's
terrific and she would ever do a house
you know she was I had a conversation
with Russell Simmons free free brilliant
man but pre all these sexual allegations
the this summer I've won a championship
I rented a big-ass house in the hills
and I was jogging and I hear bards I
turn around for us and was like what the
[__]
so we end up hanging out whatever and
this is you know this is 2017 summer 17
so he's just like you know Trump ends up
coming up and he's just like you know
I've known Donald for so many years and
the Donnell I know wasn't a racist and
you know he had wrote scriptures in my
book snows my children all this kind of
stuff and I I opposed this to him I'm
just like what if Trump is so smart that
he knew what demographic he had to go
after you know like Obama wheat turned
out in record numbers he was a Democrat
so we you know he used to talk so much
[__] about Republican yes applicants are
stupid this is never the Iraq war right
yeah so I told my I'm just like what if
Trump knew just like Obama brought
minorities out for the first like we
felt we had it like we had a voice now
so he did the same thing for the
rednecks racist people he knew the
audience he had to talk to and now he's
so far in that just that good old boy is
kind of coming out of him sob not
necessary Reese's he may not but I think
more than being racist he's just smart
and he knew who he had to cater to to
cheat and get in a trumpet yes also
about yes and I mean he's he
there's not a more personal I don't
think you want to be President I think
he got that I think Howard Stern spoke
on this he got there's like dude this
white house is a dump
yeah easy guys do all this like yeah DC
I don't live here
it was a so right now it's a needle but
she went again I just wish you could
bring people you can say everything you
want to say about Obama but when there
was a time for a speech that was gonna
calm the nation there is not a [__]
problem that you know they come in and
you just you just hope for that everyone
smart for Trump cuz like you said you
can point you can I don't even follow
the good things he's done but I know
Trump has done some good things but the
reason why I don't give them the benefit
of the doubt with any of that because I
can't put up with hey dividing yeah I
can't you know we gotta be together and
people understand like there's so many
more biracial kids now like in 15 10 15
years everyone's gonna be mixed up a
brown you know I mean everyone is gonna
be mixed I mean we have to understand we
have to understand that it's just like
it's that's what's coming he says that
like he'll tweet something he'll go are
these protests are looting in a Doozer I
will not them I will not let them
they're dis honoring the memory of
George Floyd I will not then let that
happen I'm like good good so far but any
put that was that was a quote from a
Miami in 1968 who is a racist who said
if they they think they've seen police
brutality in many days nothing like yeah
you can't do that you can't did you have
to ruin I I was like man witness Trump
gonna speak on these rights stuff like
thank him that you think we need
military and you hear the call he had
with all the governors you know oh
they're laughing they're laughing oh
you're weak you're this he's I got
enforce it you don't give him a hand man
he's he's he he would be a dictator he
is an authoritarian what's disappointing
last he brought the subject have you
seen the picture that leaked of him
spray tanning and you you know you would
think President United States probably
so vain you have hog yeah there's
nothing there mama it is an all pubic
hair its is enough it's like he's
butt-naked in spray tan looks horrible
oh damn
good then they got mono he is he is
orange he really is a thorn to go so one
said something's like do we gotta do
something he puts makeup on guys
yeah look at his eyes though bro I know
this word he means get his lids done I'm
getting mothers do you mean so you see
how you have eyelids this whole time but
yeah so they take tight you wants you
want I will definitely notice but by the
way I go under the knife on on the 16th
I cannot wait you're like I'm coming
back in your next yeah I know I live is
you go to kuda looking yeah we now we
just do a second we do all the current
events that will get you a new Matt
Barnes you've been great man we want you
on there for a while right yeah been a
long podcast dude you've been I've
wondered on it for a while people on the
planet I appreciate it man thank you
I gotta get my I got to get wider tire
so I can become a big boy biking cuz I'm
tired right now yes I got a custom bike
made for me we should ride man come down
then you live on my area yeah let's do
it yeah let's go do some boxing smoke
though all the smoke show to show to you
so you have a new show coming out yeah
but that's up in the area so broken rim
coming to you soon
I don't know what platform hopefully
Showtime but if not it'll be Netflix
stars all the smoke is it's so good yeah
I mean we can finish it you know it's
been a special run a fun run I've
learned so much I knew nothing about
podcast coming in this game I just know
working for ESPN which is a Disney
Network I have to walk a fine line when
this I can be me you know and I think
there was such a negative persona or
perception of who I was as a player and
myself and Jack of late we've been able
to shed who people think we are in Sean
or who we are you know we just kind of
want to do our part to make a different
difference in in the world but you know
when we bring you content to humanize
our guests you know we gave people
another side of Kobe you get people on
the other side of KD we gave people the
other side of Steph and I think that
being able to humanize our guests and
let people know like we are the same as
you we just happen to get paid a lot of
money but we still have the same
life emotional roller coasters that
everyone else goes through and we're
here for you
first and foremost yeah so so good well
we love you man thanks for coming on
breath and gentlemen that part here this
fine kid we're out